en la Cumbre de la comunidad política
Europea el presidente francés Emmanuel
macron reafirmó el compromiso de Francia
con el envío de más ayuda militar a kiev
mientras voló el ingreso de su país a la
otan
en la noche del miércoles la cámara de
representantes de Estados Unidos aprobó
el proyecto para Elevar el techo de la
deuda ahora el texto pasa al senado que
debe aprobarlo antes del 5 de junio para
evitar que el país entre en impago
conectamos con Washington
nayib bukele cumple cuatro años en la
presidencia de El Salvador y es el
mandatario más popular de América Latina
a pesar de las denuncias en su contra
por violaciones a los derechos humanos
en el marco de su guerra contra las
pandillas
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
maceu y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
abrimos esta edición informativa en
moldavia donde 50 líderes de Europa se
reúnen en la Cumbre de la comunidad
política europea un foro que agrupa a
los 27 miembros del bloque comunitario y
a otras potencias del continente como
Reino Unido o Turquía el encuentro se
celebró por primera vez el año pasado a
iniciativa del presidente francés
Emmanuel macron quien en su discurso
planteó que es el momento de repensar la
Unión Europea ante las candidaturas de
ingreso de países como el anfitrión de
este encuentro moldavia y por otro lado
macron reafirmó su compromiso con la
ayuda militar a kiev
hemos podido reafirmar nuestro apoyo a
Ucrania que desde hace un año sufre la
agresión rusa esta mañana me reuní con
el presidente zelensky e hicimos una
declaración afirmando el apoyo en
términos de preparar la contraofensiva
reafirmamos nuestro acuerdo celebrado el
14 de mayo del 2023 sobre los elementos
de protección contra los ataques rusos
como elementos de defensa aérea y que
estamos dispuestos en la formación de
los pilotos de casa
y otra de las cuestiones que abordó
Emanuel macron en su discurso fue la
candidatura de Ucrania a la otan el
mandatario francés Se declaró a favor de
ofrecer más garantías de seguridad a
kiev y una respuesta Clara a Moscú y no
descartó volver a conversar con Vladimir
Putin sin embargo no fue más allá
recordemos a que el ingreso de Ucrania
la otan divide a los miembros de la
alianza porque escalaría la guerra en
Ucrania a nivel transatlántico sin
embargo también en moldavia voló
dimmerce lensky insistió en su petición
es absolutamente Claro que la otan tiene
las garantías de infraestructura de
seguridad necesarias para Ucrania Pero
qué sería no estar en la otan ahora
Estamos hablando con países como Estados
Unidos y otros aliados y estamos
hablando de los paquetes de seguridad
basados en las garantías que necesitamos
porque somos nosotros los que tenemos
esta guerra y estamos pagando con
nuestras propias vidas y entendemos lo
que necesitamos y necesitamos estas
garantías de seguridad por qué Porque no
estamos en la otan de otra forma Rusia
no nos atacaría o si nos atacará
estaríamos protegidos por la otan Aunque
Sigo creyendo que no nos atacarían
vamos ahora con noticias sobre el
terreno de la Guerra de Ucrania porque a
primera hora de este jueves un nuevo
ataque ruso contra kiev mató a tres
civiles entre ellos una niña la ofensiva
también dañó edificios residenciales
escuelas y una clínica
las consecuencias de los últimos ataques
rusos contra kiev Aunque Ucrania afirma
que sus defensas aéreas interceptaron
los 10 misiles balísticos y de crucero
iscandar los restos que cayeron dañaron
edificios residenciales una guardería y
una clínica matando a varias personas
entre ellas una menor
hubo una alerta aérea la gente corría al
Refugio fue largo mi mujer y mi hijo
estaban allí El niño está bien pero mi
mujer murió
yo había ido al lado opuesto para
preguntar sobre la apertura del Refugio
en ese momento ocurrió
un en vivo corrían hacia aquí para
esconderse pero estaba cerrado por
desgracia estábamos fuera cayó justo
entre la policlínica y la guardería
[Música]
el ataque del jueves por la mañana fue
el décimo octavo en la capital ucraniana
desde principios de mayo
Moscú ha intensificado sus ataques con
misiles y drones mientras kiev se
prepara para lanzar una contraofensiva
una táctica que según analistas pretende
agotar las defensas aéreas ucranianas
que necesitan munición Mientras tanto el
crimen acusa a kiev de intensificar los
ataques en las zonas fronterizas rusas
el miércoles el gobernador de belgorot
anunció que evacuarían a los niños de la
región tras el mortífero ataque de
principios de semana dos personas más
resultaron heridas en belgo la primera
hora del jueves en el último ataque
atribuido por Rusia a las tropas
ucranianas
cambiamos de tema vamos a Estados Unidos
que está más cerca de evitar el impago
la cámara de representantes aprobó ayer
el proyecto para suspender el techo de
la deuda hasta 2025 a cambio de
importantes recortes en gasto público
ahora el texto debe ser tramitado en el
senado antes del lunes 5 de junio la
fecha límite estimada por el
departamento del tesoro para ampliar
conectamos ahora con una Cristóbal
Vázquez nuestro corresponsal en
Washington Cristóbal Buenas tardes para
usted le planteo la votación de anoche
evidenció fracturas dentro del partido
republicano como del demócrata no es así
Así es fracturas por un lado del lado
republicano los más conservadores en el
partido republicano no están contentos
con que solo se haya acordado aumentar
el gasto en defensa un tres coma tres
por ciento el próximo año y tampoco
están contentos porque querían más
recortes en los gastos esta precisamente
fue la condición que ponían los
republicanos para aprobar este proyecto
para levantar el techo de la deuda que
separara el gasto público hubieran
recortes de parte de el gobierno en
programas sociales los demócratas por
otro lado Pues están Precisamente en
desacuerdo y no muy contentos con el
hecho de que se hayan congelado los
gastos en programas sociales de aquí al
2025 sobre todo en cuanto a subsidios de
alimentación a las personas de escasos
recursos en Estados Unidos
y además argumentan que dado que se
congela estos programas esta
financiación a programas sociales en
Estados Unidos la inflación va a
terminar haciendo que en términos reales
haya una reducción en los gastos a
programas sociales en Estados Unidos
teniendo en cuenta que la inflación
supera el 5% acá es decir en los
próximos dos años va a haber un recorte
real en esta inversión social en Estados
Unidos y a eso no le apuntaron los
demócratas inicialmente sin embargo los
moderados aprobaron en la cámara de
representantes este proyecto y se espera
que también sea el caso en el senado
Cristóbal como lo decía a pesar de las
divisiones finalmente se aprobó en la
cámara de representantes y como usted
nos acaba de mencionar ahora Pasa este
texto al senado que se sabe de lo que va
a suceder en esta cámara y cuándo qué
tiempos habría en esta votación
pues Beach mccono que es el líder de La
minoría republicana en la cámara alta es
decir en el senado dijo incluso que la
votación se podría dar hoy mismo lo que
están tratando de hacer
que es el líder demócrata en el senado
de hecho es el líder del senado teniendo
en cuenta que tiene la mayoría del
partido demócrata en la cámara alta Pues
están tratando de negociar con
algunos senadores que han dicho que van
a tratar de hacer enmiendas a este
proyecto de ley que fue aprobado en la
cámara de representante anoche y
entonces lo que quieren Precisamente es
que estas enmiendas no demoren en el
proceso teniendo en cuenta que no hay
tiempo para poder gastar en debates de
pequeñas enmiendas en este proyecto
entonces de hecho hoy en la plenaria del
senado dijo que en las sesiones van a
continuar abiertas hasta que se haga la
votación y pues hay esperanzas de que
sea hoy mismo
tardar mañana viernes que haya ya el
voto definitivo lo que dicen analistas
legislativos acá en Washington es que el
paso por el senado es muy positivo
teniendo en cuenta que ya los dos
partidos han expresado su apoyo
públicamente a este proyecto de ley es
decir lo único que falta es tratar de
animar esas asperezas en las enmiendas
que quieren hacer algunos senadores para
que se vote se vote a favor y el
proyecto de ley vaya a la mesa del
presidente
Cristóbal pues muchas gracias volveremos
a conectar cuando se dé esta votación
finalmente nosotros continuamos en el
continente americano porque hoy 1 de
junio el presidente de El Salvador nayib
bukele completa cuatro años en el poder
y pocos mandatarios generan reacciones
tan opuestas como él y es que mientras
es el mandatario más popular de la
región por reducir la criminalidad en un
país que llegó a ser el más inseguro del
mundo organizaciones internacionales de
defensa de los Derechos Humanos lo
acusan de masivas violaciones
precisamente contra los derechos humanos
en el marco de su estado de excepción
que dura ya más de un año Andrés triviño
nos amplía
con un estilo fresco y la promesa de
hacer una política distinta nayib bukele
asumió Hace cuatro años la presidencia
de El Salvador ustedes dirán Cómo
quieren ser gobernados porque hoy
tendremos lo del pueblo
bukele Ha logrado captar la atención de
la comunidad internacional por sus
controversiales políticas y decisiones
calificadas como autoritarias una de
ellas se registró el 9 de febrero de
2020 cuando el mandatario tomó junto con
el ejército la asamblea legislativa tras
la negativa de los diputados para
aprobar la financiación de su plan de
seguridad hasta que finalmente lo
consiguió el plan de control territorial
es la estrategia insignia del mandatario
para acabar con las pandillas del país
que controlaban el 80% del territorio y
para 2015 llevó a El Salvador a tener la
tasa de homicidios más alta del mundo
queda aprobado el proyecto de decreto lo
que hizo que el 27 de marzo de 2022 El
Congreso aprobará por pedido de bukele
un régimen de excepción vigente hasta la
fecha como respuesta a una escalada de
violencia que en un solo día dejó 62
muertos la medida permite capturas sin
orden judicial e incluso a aquellos que
tengan tatuajes además el presidente
inauguró una mega cárcel con capacidad
para albergar cerca de 40.000 detenidos
el gobierno difunde con orgullo imágenes
de los presos descalzos Encadenados y
ordenados perfectamente
según bukele hasta el 10 de mayo el país
completó 365 días no continuos sin
homicidios medidas que cuentan con más
del 90% de la aprobación Popular según
encuestas pero con el rechazo de la
comunidad internacional la gente le está
diciendo al gobierno aquí estamos y no
estamos de acuerdo en ciertas políticas
que usted está haciendo anteriormente
era difícil sobrevivir
a uno no sabía si volvía a llegar a
regresar a la casa otra vez la
popularidad de bukele quedaría
demostrada en las urnas en 2024 tras
anunciar su intención de lanzarse por
reelección a pesar de ser
inconstitucional Según la ley
salvadoreña
vamos a Australia porque el soldado vivo
más condecorado del país perdió una
demanda por difamación contra varios
periódicos nacionales Ben Roberts Smith
había demandado a los medios de
comunicación por publicaciones que le
acusaban de crímenes de guerra en
Afganistán pero el juez Consideró que la
mayoría de esos informes eran ciertos
veamos
un día de ajuste de cuentas para el
veterano de guerra vivo más condecorado
de Australia un tribunal de sidney
dictaminó que tres periódicos no
difamaron al ex soldado de élite de los
servicios aéreos especiales Ben Robert
Smith cuando informaron de su
implicación en los asesinatos de seis
prisioneros desarmados en Afganistán
entre 2009 y 2012 una reivindicación
para los periodistas que informaron de
la historia
para aquellos valientes hombres del país
que se levantaron y dijeron la verdad
sobre quién es Ben Roberts Smith un
criminal de guerra un matón y un
mentiroso Hoy es el Día de un poco de
Justicia para las víctimas afganas de
Ben Roberts Smith
Robert Smith Recibió la máxima
condecoración militar del país la cruz
Victoria en 2011 por su valentía en el
campo de batalla afgano pero en 2018 de
City morning Herald de Camera Times y de
Age publicaron informes en los que se le
acusaba de crímenes de guerra incluyendo
arrojar a un granjero por un acantilado
y matarlo a tiros dispararon prisionero
por la espalda antes de tomar su pierna
prostética para un recipiente para beber
y ordenar al menos otros dos asesinatos
Robert Smith negó haber cometido delito
alguno y presentó una demanda millonaria
por daños y perjuicios publicaron la
historia de esta magnitud Nunca es fácil
pero el periodismo de investigación de
alta calidad es vital para una
democracia prosperada
Robert Smith aún no se ha enfrentado a
cargos penales por los asesinatos se
espera más acciones legales mientras
Australia recapacita sobre su papel en
la guerra afgana una investigación
militar de 2020 descubrió que las
fuerzas especiales habían matado
ilegalmente a 39 prisioneros y civiles
llevamos así al final de esta edición
pero sigan con nosotros que enseguida
volvemos
[Música]